und im park prozess verfolgt für uns
jörg völkerling york du hast jetzt die
eltern des getöteten bei dir ja biete
und katja konrad sind bei mir sie haben
große erwartungen diesen prozess gehabt
sie haben viele fragen gehabt aber der
angeklagte km ist die antworten schuldig
geblieben er hat nur über seinen anwalt
erklären lassen dass die anklage 100
prozent korrekt sei und dass er alles
bereue was getan was er getan hat es
hätte im leben nie erwartet dass in
seinem lauf der pistole noch eine
pistole stecken eine munition steckte
eine kugel polizei der polizist zu sein
sei immer sein traum gewesen und diesen
traum können ja nun nicht mehr ausleben
er seit der tat suspendiert ist jetzt
wieder schüler
er hat im gespräch mit einem psychologen
die tat geschildert und gesagt julian
und er hätten an dem abend rumgealbert
mit der waffe und mit einem schlagstock
con sie hätten in notwehr schuss
angedeutet und gegeneinander angelegt
julian habe zuerst die waffe gezogen was
seltsam ist denn nach dem tatort
befunden berichtet wurde die waffe im
holster des getöteten gefunden
das sind sie ist eine der widersprüche
die hier zur sprache gekommen sind und
ich habe jetzt hier neben mir
peter und die mutter von julian konrad
und ihren anwalt jürgen scholl
vielleicht können sie einfach wir sind
vom verlauf der warnung bis dahin sehr
sehr enttäuscht weil es fast aus sich
nur um die befindlichkeit des
angeklagten geht und nicht um das ganz
toll was für fragen haben die eltern was
hatten sie sich erhofft von diesem
prozess werden uns zumindest er hofft
dass auch noch mal die übergabe dieses
magazins und das ist ihr geht in dem
sich diese kugel nicht mehr befahren
sondern schon in der waffe des
angeklagten das ist genauer vom gericht
beleuchtet wird das erscheint uns etwas
sehr zu knapp geraten zu sein
auch die staatsanwaltschaft hätte da
unserer ansicht nach mehr nachfragen
stellen müssen natürlich ist die frage
nach der verantwortlichkeit der
organisation dieser schule heute nicht
in diesem prozess zu klären
gleichwohl hätte es das gesamtbild
abgerundet und spielt natürlich auch für
die schuld des angeklagten der rolle
wir meinen wie gesagt die ermittlungen
bzw auch die aufführung im gericht hätte
etwas ausführlicher auf aushalten müssen
und deswegen verstehe meine mandanten
wenn sie sehr enttäuscht sind weil wie
gesagt auch die tatsache dass hier sehr
viel über den angeklagten getötet worden
ist verstört sind natürlich weil sie
wollten wirklich eine antwort warum ist
unser so nicht mehr bei uns obwohl wir
ihn in die obhut der bayerischen polizei
zur ausbildung gegeben haben ja vielen
dank herr scholl das urteil will der
richter bernd krieger schon in wenigen
minuten sprechen also um 12 48 wird es
hier am amtsgericht würzburg weitergehen
man merkt dem richter an dass er das
bemühen hat hier dieses verfahren sehr
schnell durchzuziehen und auch die
öffentlichkeit möglich sehr zu begrenzen
corona gibt ihm die möglichkeit sogar
die presseplätze waren auf lediglich
zwei limitiert dankeschön jörg
völkerling das portal erfahren natürlich
auch bei uns bei bild de und in der 18
uhr sendungen vielen dank